[Music]
so did you guys know
uh
about the burj khalifa what about that
it exists it is indeed the world's
tallest building
it is need standing at 2 716 feet it is
indeed
uh something that is so tall that people
on the top of the building and on the
bottom of the building have a different
read of time itself whoa shut the [ __ ]
up that's great for real
so like you're standing on the upper
floors of the bridge khalifa right the
world's tallest building and you will
look down
on like say the sun is setting
and you're you're seeing the sun setting
um
over there but down
at the bottom the sun doesn't set for a
while after that makes sense again what
the [ __ ] are you talking about why are
you so surprised i was talking about
like the [ __ ] quantum physics and
science behind like interstellar using
the idea of gravity as like i did turn
to time you know what i mean so well no
a baby born at the top
it's actually like 30 months younger
once again shut the [ __ ] up
i remember reading that too
you take the elevator you come out
everybody else is 40 years older
what year is it you know the sun is
setting sooner
for a guy that's outside
versus you inside
because you don't know yet until you go
outside especially in this building
everybody here is like what's happening
uh yeah so one of the craziest one of
the craziest things is from the top of
the birds right you can see so far into
the arabian desert that you see the sun
set several minutes after people on the
ground see it set
and it it had imp
implications for the muslim population
in the building as a result of the
perceived time difference those living
on the higher floors of the birds need
to wait a few extra minutes before
breaking their fast for ramadan
exactly
so it's like this weird thing like if
you're in a certain floor of the
building yeah oh interesting yeah and so
clerics there decided that the residents
above the 84 should wait like another
two minutes to end their fasting and
those above the 150 people really do be
waiting for that minute to start eating
it's on the money yeah they don't mess
around dude so if you're above the 154
you should wait an additional three
minutes but like we're talking about by
the way imagine having an office and
you're like dude we're at the
[ __ ] bird khalifa and be like
cool before and like
you wear the first floor
[Laughter]
take your food to the very top watch the
hallway be across the street dude who
[ __ ] gives a [ __ ] i might rather be
on the first floor than like 12. dude i
would hate to be on an elevator that
long man yeah i wonder how long it takes
to get all the way to the top you have
to go to like
it's like expressed to one floor then
switch elevators right so you gotta
really
or do you think you could watch the
sunrise on the first floor jump in the
elevator go to the top and watch it
again
you probably could the trump tower uh
elevators were hella fast really they
were fast dude from the first floor to
the 60th we're trying to get away from
liberals trump tower is better than
virgil
i would imagine the khalifa probably has
way faster mia khalifa i bet she has a
way faster elevator way better i heard
that if you're higher up in the burj
khalifa you know that it's you can feel
that it's raining sooner than the guy
because it hits you quicker so if you
can call in time but if the clouds are
under you
you don't feel the right what if you're
too high it's so tall the upper half
occasionally emerges above the clouds so
then what you just said is actually kind
of horseshit a little bit depending on
where you are
so once again don't trust the dancer
wait for the news
you know what's crazy is we're living in
the jetsons like
that's the jetsons right there at the
top of the building
but the thing
what i what i want to know is like
how like well for one how long does it
take to get out there right and if
there's different elevators like if have
you ever been to a big ass building and
then this section of elevators only go
from like one to thirty and this one
only goes from like 30 to 60 or some
[ __ ] that's how it works the university
of michigan just did a study and they
determined that at the top of the
building
the temperature on the outside is
thought to be 11 degrees fahrenheit
cooler than on the ground and the way
that they tested it was they all [ __ ]
off the top story
[Laughter]
and then they were able to see and
actually which one landed first if it
froze yeah do you know do you know about
the jetson's discrepancy
what about it because uh so like there's
the mother father uh elroy elroy and the
other daughter right they there's actual
ages that they all have yeah and if you
do the math it shows that george jetson
conceived the daughter when the wife was
underage really yeah
so he's a [ __ ] pedophile
that's so [ __ ] [ __ ] funny ass
disgrace
so today we lost charlie chaplin and
george jetson great george jetson is a
national hero
that [ __ ] ginger pedophile who do i
look up to now nobody dude belinda carla
clint eastwood
everyone disappoints you no no no
colonel john mcburney
how about fred flintstone he's he's cool
right he's wholesome yeah pedophilia was
over back then i guess there was no name
for it they were probably making a lot
of dinosaurs and stuff back then what do
you think under 18 didn't ring the same
way back then because people wouldn't
live past 35. that's fair but that's
very fair that's true anyone else have
some [ __ ] burj khalifa effects
oh [ __ ] if you if you throw a bouncy
ball
off the top of the burj khalifa yeah
that you just got
right when he said university of
michigan i was like this [ __ ] is
up to some [ __ ]
god damn it
well it doesn't work if you say
university is something that sounds good
no like everyone knows you miss songs
you have me in the first half i'll i'll
be real
michigan wants to do a [ __ ] thing for
birch we want some fat guys like yo
[ __ ] blue on top of the birds like
what would happen i'm like yeah we'll
put these little tracers in and we'll
see what happens these chasers
you never know but you know i think
you're right i think you're right about
the temperature i think you're right
thank you but the bouncy ball thing
would be crazy and they should do it but
then they're afraid of killing people
apparently they probably will kill us
the jizz thing on the ball i don't think
so no just the ball by itself
i've never been to the burj khalifa is
that do they have is that what has also
like a giant [ __ ] like mall and [ __ ]
like a skiing slope and [ __ ] like better
have one of everything in that [ __ ]
yo i saw that they have a yeah or is
that in like a building next to it it's
got it's got a lot of [ __ ] it's got a
lot of stuff yeah it has laser tag i
know that like a mall and an apartment
and a skis resort
i don't know i want to check it out and
it's not even it's not full occupancy
right it's like there's some [ __ ] that's
still yeah dude don't worry about it
there's
you want a dance studio there you got it
[Laughter]
okay i don't think i could go that's too
high for me like i don't think i can are
you scared of heights yeah i think i
don't think i'd be able to go to the top
and look down and probably pass out bro
if you watch these videos of these
[ __ ] cats
who um they go climb on all this [ __ ]
and they do all the illicit climbing
stuff and they're taking videos and
you've seen clouds and [ __ ] yeah i'm
like dude my heart sinks watching
footage yeah no
i went to one of the tallest buildings
in japan it was pretty [ __ ] scary but
then out the red one no it's taller than
that
that that thing that's tokyo tower that
looks like the [ __ ] eiffel tower yeah
there's yeah there's a skyscraper i
forgot i mean it's not it's in tokyo but
when you get to the top though
your perspective like your mind can't
even
register how far you are and then you
just kind of look and then the city is
just
it's just a [ __ ] sea of city all the
way to the horizon a bunch of likes how
long was the elevator in you had to take
like two i think
yeah is it true that the top floors or
the top levels of the burj khalifa are
like kind of useless
that they they just put them so that
they would get the record oh like the
antenna [ __ ] like that [ __ ] where
they like inspired they wrecked yeah
they wrecked the building and they put
the spire in the mass height yeah just
to like because it's still so no one
lives there that's what that's what the
korean air building in downtown l.a is
really that giant [ __ ] spire that's
on top of it i think it's literally just
to be technically the largest skyscraper
in l.a yeah cause i feel like oxygen and
stuff would be hard like right the
higher you get like the harder it is to
breathe and [ __ ] well i don't [ __ ]
know
bro you i mean you knew about the common
coming off the presenting an article get
a question i'm [ __ ] knowing this look
this is a new era this
of jk do you know
baby we're gonna admit what we don't
nation the domination
[ __ ] dick
after he says ask the host not the
dancer hey your my answer to your
question is sucky
because he doesn't care dude because i'm
[ __ ] cold because i covered myself in
water for a bit earlier
i think they're uh digging up [ __ ]
like venice style canals in uh dubai
around the burj khalifa so that you
could take [ __ ] like little speed
boats and stuff around in order to get
from place to place she's kind of sick
it's actually really sick and as a
straight white man i would love to go to
dubai
yeah because i'm not gay and like i'm
not a woman
i think i would just do really well i
think i would really thrive there do
really well they need to do marketing
specifically for that guy i think i
think they should cut me into promos for
it and like a lot of dudes with them you
could promote your steve rollups dude
yeah steve for [ __ ] miss a place that
had traditional values
miss a place where women had to just
cover up and uh you never really hear
like from like super gay guys like
someday i want to go to dubai no no no
no
no dubai was lit comes from straight
white men yeah
no they could they could probably like
you know keep it a little low-key is
that suppressive was that like the kid
who went to the dentist or some [ __ ]
it's like dubai was lit yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and everyone started saying that [ __ ]
was lit you've been you've been to dubai
i haven't i haven't it's not that great
i got a buddy i got a buddy who went and
he was rich enough where he could still
drink there and stuff so he had a great
time they had an entire floor just for
them and they could do whatever the [ __ ]
they wanted ryan what's
what's your opinion on dubai no i just
think i just think it's it's difficult
if you're not like totally
crazy about sharia law
you know like it's if you're not going
gaga
yeah if you're not a big fan for sharia
law
all due respect to like whatever your
culture is but like
it's just it's such a culture shock
because it's like here you have a place
that like literally is made of just such
riches and it has all this great stuff
but you just can't do anything that you
normally do how about i eat a hamburger
you can't be the way you want to be i
like hamburgers wow i'm straight so i
probably could and i'm and i'm white so
i probably could do both but i guess
it's it's not it's not too it's not
privileged that's just dubai that's just
how dubai is dude it's like the same
scheme like it's the same formulas here
we're like oh yeah certain amounts of
money will get you certain liberties but
there the spread is just way thicker
yeah it's like oh those liberties you
get in la yeah those are way the [ __ ] up
here now you know what i mean
and you need way more money for it you
need way more money for that [ __ ] yeah
but you go to the top of the mirror
khalifa what's going on
what the hell what's it called another
top of me i believe yeah yeah the the
building
it's like five foot two damn that sounds
so funny it's called the it's called the
burj latifah we met nina we met him
she was in this room
yeah he she brought he brought her up
don't see me
what'd you say dude
jk classics
[Music]
you